Right. Yes, guys. Welcome back to
another one. And today we hit two break
even trades.
>> Order filled.
>> The date of the 21st, no, the 20th of
January. And this was the London macro
longs that we took. So we had a shift in
market structure on both NQ and ES and
then we inverse that order block on ES.
So this was valid. We had a bullish
price. So we sweep the sell side. This
was clean. So, we prematurely entered
off the tap of ES and we're taking this
with a seven contract size as the stop
placement was a little bit bigger than
anticipated. So, simply match the dollar
amount of your contract sizing and it's
not an issue. So going into this trade,
uh we're looking to trade our stops as
usual at the first short-term high and
then we would manage to trade as we see
price action move in our favor. But this
did end up being break even and you will
see how that plays out. So there we have
it. Marked out the first short-term
high. That's where we ch stop. So this
is basically already break even.
Majority of the risk is taken off just
from the first short-term might being
swept. We don't want to see price return
to that point of the short-term low.
Then we'll be taken out of the position.
And this is how you have key risk
management, guys. Absolutely key. It's
so key
because in the long run, that is how
you're actually going to
maximize your profits. because you could
be hitting bangers after bangers after
bangers, but then if you're taking full
stopouts, you know, there's a lot of
scenarios where you can avoid actually
getting stopped out of that amount and
that will actually compound into being
quite a substantial amount over the
course of the year or the month or the
quarter that you've actually lost when
if you simply charge your stops as your
plan says. So then you would have lost
way less and that's why you know risk
management is absolutely key. It's
absolutely key to follow your system
and you know like there's some people
who would close out at the high or you
know as it's getting close they'll like
panic and stuff like you need to realize
that you need to follow your system
because if you are just closing out
early you will see you will lose out on
so much profits and your risk-to-reward
is just completely cooked. So, you know,
some people say, "Oh, risk of reward
doesn't matter as long as you're making
money on the trade." Yes. All right.
Making money on the trade. But, you
know, who's going to be making more?
Someone who follows their plan that is
consistent and they know is profitable
over the course of a year where you know
if it's a break even trade, it's a break
even trade. That was trade wasn't meant
to win. It all plays into the parts of
the probabilities.
Whereas someone who just closes out
early and then when they actually do get
close to they're not hitting any full
TPS because then that horrible habit of
just closing out early when it's getting
close to TP, you know, it's it's it can
be very harming.
But yeah, at the time of recording this
right now, I'm uh we're going to be
moving to a new apartment in two days
time before we then head back to the UK
cuz
you know, I've spent a decent amount of
time here, two and a half weeks.
And you know, I've been very happy with
the experience. Now it's time to go back
and reflect, see if this place is the
right fit for me.
But yeah, we can see here that
price is moving a little bit choppy at
the start of here and we could
potentially be seeing a move lower. I
mean, we are trading into a fivem minute
bearish gap. With these reversal trades,
you're always going to be trading into a
fivem minute bearish or bullish gap.
It's very highly unlikely that you're
actually not trading into a reversal
gap,
which is why you'd usually need the
other biases to be aligned as well
because in this scenario, price didn't
tap into the five. Uh, actually, no, I
think the bias on the screen is wrong.
At the time, it was wrong. I have it.
It's not that I had it wrong that I
didn't know what it was, but I had it in
my head. I already saw the time frames.
I just didn't bother changing it. Uh
well, maybe it is correct. I don't even
I can't even remember. But the bus is
100% bullish. But what I'm trying to say
is Yeah, there you go. I deleted it
because I was like I don't want it to
mislead people to think that's why it
was. But it must have been like the 1
hour I think was bullish as well because
price had dropped a substantial amount
since the first London macro. So we're
currently inside of the second London
macro.
And there we go. So price does take that
short-term high there.
And that's where I would move my stop to
break even. On some of my prop firm
accounts, I have moved my stop to the
short-term low where you see that black
line where I've drawn it out. That's the
short-term low. I did move some of my
stops there. But for my live account
that you can see right here on screen,
I've kept it just at break even. Just at
break even.
just in case it did sweep below and want
to go higher. I gave price a little bit
of wiggle room, but you can see how
aggressive price was coming. So, I was
like, "Yeah, I'm I'm just close this.
This is going to stop me out."
Yeah. Out of that one. So, lovely stuff,
guys. I'll catch you in the next video.
Thank you for watching and peace.